you started with an idea a problem to be
solved a vision to be shared you welcome
a life of late nights you mean business
red eyes red bull ready to do it all
again you're making progress but it's
hard to tell if you're headed in the
right direction the thing is what you're
looking for isn't out there it's here
the stanford adventure studio get
structure and support and network to
enable your ideas
these guys didn't do it alone and
neither should you you need a team
collaboration connection what better
place to meet your new cto cfo and cmo
you need a place to work a place to
build you want someone who's been there
before
get a tried and true veteran of the
industry of your industry learn from
your failures your successes at the
stanford venture studio you can stay on
campus learn the nuts and bolts of
entrepreneurship and gain experience
this is your design lab your conference
room your think tank who says there has
to be a trade-off between being a
student and being an entrepreneur at the
stanford venture studio they go hand in
hand this isn't about making
entrepreneurship easier it's about
living your idea join us at the stanford
venture studio